they've had enough enough of Thailand's
military rulers enough of seeing their
rights curtailed enough of promised
elections being pushed back time and
time again
now these protesters in the heart of
Bangkok say they won't back down until
the government makes good on its promise
to let the people have their say we're
living with the Parliament that has no
opposition opposition for the last five
years without any you know good
governance or any no opposition working
in the Parliament so the day's election
is very important for Thailand not only
to go back to democracy but also to form
the country back again after five years
and to get their rights as citizens back
in the past five years the military
government has used its powers to stop
critics from speaking out until recently
protests like this one were prohibited
by the strict assembly law Thailand's
military dictatorship put in place now
that law has been lifted but in spite of
that demonstrators are still telling me
that they're being harassed by the
authorities the police called me and
then he he tried to convince me and
forced me to not put his penis like that
put me in a coffee shop for a few days
had finished but these tactics aren't
keeping activists away they're afraid
the government could play for time until
the election deadline set by Thailand's
Constitution expires then there would be
no telling when Thais would get to vote
again
[Music]
you